كيف تصف الوضع في
أفغانستان اليوم ،
أعتقد
أنه من
المقلق أن تكون
أفغانستان
على مفترق طرق تاريخي
واحد
إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام ونصلي أن
يعمل هذا في
اتجاه السلام بعد 40 عامًا في أفغانستان
إذا
سيطر هذا الطالبان على كل أفغانستان
وإذا كان
بإمكانهم العمل الآن نوعًا ما نحو
حكومة شاملة
تجمع جميع الفصائل معًا ،
فيمكن لأفغانستان أن تحصل على سلام بعد 40
عامًا ، ولكن إذا سارت الأمور على نحو خاطئ
، وهذا ما نشعر بالقلق حياله
فقد يؤدي إلى
الفوضى أكبر أزمة إنسانية ،
وهو لاجئ ضخم  مشكلة
أفغانستان غير المستقرة
والسبب في دخول الولايات المتحدة هو
مكافحة
الإرهاب أو الإرهاب الدولي
غير المستقر أزمة اللاجئين الأفغان
واحتمال عودة
الإرهاب من أراضي أفغانستان